ابرز احداث الرياضه في 2002 2022
ومشاكل بالجمله للفنانين مصر هذا العام
وحتى الان 50 فنانا لتكريم صوت الارض اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
بكل نهايه عام بيكون ابرز الاحداث
الرياضيه اللي صارت على مدار السنه حصه
كبيره من الاخبار عام 2022 بدا بترحيل نجم
كره المضرب
من استراليا والسبب انه ما كان اخذ لقاح
فيروس كورونا وملتزم كمان بالقوانين
المفروضه على الوافدين الموضوع نفسه كمان
منعوا من السفر الى الولايات المتحده
وحرمه من المشاركه ببطوله الولايات
المتحده المفتوحه وما بدنا ننسى حدا كتير
مهم بعالم الرياضه كمان صار هاي السنه وهو
استبعاد روسيا وحلفتها بلا روسيا من
الرياضه العالميه والسبب اللي ما خلى
روسيا تشارك بنهائي كاس العالم ولا بلا
روسيا العاب القوه ومن عمليات الاستبعاد
للفضه اللي صارت نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا
كره القدم في 28 مايو بالعاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس والفوضى كان سببها انه الالاف من
مشجعين ليفربول الانجليزي ما قادره يوصلوا
للملعب لحتى يتابعوا المباراه ضد ريال
مدريد الاسباني
وتعرض المشجعين او المشجعون من حاملي
التذاكر له هجوم كمان بالغاز المسير
للدموع من قبل الشرطه وتوهم بمحاوله دخول
الملعب بشكل غير قانوني عموما يا جماعه
بدايه العام كانت بترحيله زي ما قلنا بس
انتهى بالحدث الاجمل وهي مباريات كاس
العالم واللي كانت مليئه بالمفاجات
افتتاحيه المباريات وما في شك انه كانت
بالفعل الاجمل كانت في الفوز التاريخي
اللي حققه المنتخب السعودي على الارجنتين
ليكون وقتها ابطال الاخضر هما اول فريق
بيهز شباك مرمى الارجنتين وكمان الوحيد
اللي بيفوز عليه في كاس العالم مش بس هيك
المنتخب المغربي يعني حقق اكثر من فوز على
منتخبات عالميه وزئير اسوده ما راح ينسينا
فوزه على اسبانيا والبرتغال تونس كمان
حققت فوز نوعي على المنتخب الفرنسي المصنف
من اقوى المنتخبات عالميا
من المنتخبات العربيه للاجنبيه فحقق
المنتخب الياباني فوز مستحق على المنتخب
الالماني وما بدنا ننسى طبعا فوز كرواتيا
على البرازيل اللي كان كفيل انه يبكي
نيمار ويستبعد فريق السامبا عن حلم كاس
العالم عموما احداث جدا شيقه تبعناها طوال
فتره المباريات بس المباراه النهائيه اللي
تواجه فيها فريق التانجو والارجنتيني مع
الديوك الفرنسيه كانت بالفعل حاميه الوطيس
وانتهت بفوز الارجنتين بضربات الترجيح بعد
ما كان التعادل هو سيد الموقف بهذا الفوز
حقق اللاعب الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي حلمه
بوضع النجمه الثالثه على شعار
[موسيقى]
ايام قليله وحتى حتى نكون دقيقتين اكثر
اربع ايام فقط بتفصلنا عن السنه الجديده
وان شاء الله اكيد تكون سنه خير على
الجميع يارب لكن خلالها السنه صارت مواقف
كثيره راح تضل عالقه ومستحيل الناس تنساها
خصوصا شو كان عم بيصير مع بعض النجوم بمصر
مثلا خلينا نبدا مع شيرين عبد الوهاب اللي
ما في يوم غاب اسمها الاخبار لدرجه انها
تصدرت محركات البحث لمده اشهر من هذا
العام سبب الاساسي كلنا همم نعرفه او
عرفناه مرات وتحدثت عنه السوشال ميديا
مرات كثيره وغطيناه احنا كمان هو خلافاتها
مع زوجها حسام حبيب اللي مفصلت عنه
واعلانات الحرب عليه لكن بعدها بفتره
قصيره تفاجئ حبي شيرين
الموضوع ما توقف هون لانه شيرين رجعته
طلعت من المصحه واعلى انها تعودتها لحسام
حبيب مره يعني بدون اي مقدمات واللي لحد
الان شيرين ما طلعت ولا حكت عنك كواليس
حياتها بالاشهر الاخيره
عموما مش بس شيرين كانت عم بتواجهها ازمات
بمصر كمان الفنانه منه شلبي اللي تم
توقيفها بمطار القاهره وهي راجع من السفر
والمفاجاه انه لقوا معها مواد مخدره
النيابه العامه بعدها حالتها لا محكمه
الجنايات بدهم التعاطي مخدر الحشيش
والاحاله اكيد عملت صدمه كبيره بالوسط
الفن المصري
ان شلبي بنروح للفنان المصري محمد رمضان
اللي كان له حظ وافر من الاسماء هذه السنه
بدايه من خلافه الشهير والقضايا المتبادل
المتبادله ما بينه وما بين الاعلام المصري
عمرو اديب وصول طبعا له مطالبات بالغاء
حفل رمضان في الاسكندريه
وطبعا راح نكمل بالازمات والان مع تصريحات
كمان لا الهام شاهين اللي عملت ازمه كبيره
بينها وبين الفنانه المعتزله ميار البلوي
بسبب الهام شاهين او بسبب رفضها او همم
الحقيقه يعني الهام شاهين رفضه انه ترد
على هذه الاتهامات ونفس الامر كمان صار مع
الهام شاهين وغاده ابراهيم وقتها
الهام شاهين من انها تكون موجوده بجنازه
سمير صبري لا تخرج غاده ابراهيم وتهاجمها
بشده لكن الهام قررت تجاهلها وعدم الرد
وطبعا احنا لسه ما خلصنا لانه نقابه
الموسيقيين كمان ما خلت من الاسماك حيث او
ما خليت من الاسمنت لانه همم هاني فاكر
همم نقيب الفنانين سابقا استقال بسبب
مشاده وقعت خلال مؤتمر صحفي كان في وبعده
حل مصطفى كامل همم محله بمنصب نقيب
الموسيقيين لكن كامل دخل بيزمات سريعه
كمان عدد من شعب الغناء وداخل النقابه
تحديدا واصدر قرارات كثيره بمنع بعض
الفنانين من الغناء
اسم جديد الان في عالم التوقعات اليوم
ظهر على تويتر وهو سياسي روسي تخيلوا بس
توقعاته الناريه عملت جدل اكثر مما
بتتخيلوا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي يا
جماعه بنحكي عن تغريدات نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي دي متر يعني شو دخله
بالتوقعات والتنجيم همم هو همم توقعات
مستقبليه لعام 2023 توقعات مادبه كانت
عباره عن كوارث راح تطيح بالعالم وقال انه
اكتار بيعمل وفرضيات مستقبليه وبيتوقعوا
اشياء غير متوقع حدوثها من هذا المنطلق هو
قرر انه يتوقع احداث ممكن تصير بهذا العام
الجاي اللي هو 2003
اشياء ممكن يصيروا بالعلم السنه الجايه
منها زياده اسعار النفط
150$ للبرميل والغاز همم 5,000$
بالاضافه الى عوده بريطانيا للاتحاد
الاوروبي وكمان انهيار الاتحاد الاوروبي
بعد عوده اسبريطانيا وتوقع ايضا مدفادف
كثير من التوقعات ما خلصت هون على فكره هو
قال كمان بانه ب 2023 بولندا وهنجاريا راح
يستولوا على مناطق غربيه من اوكرانيا
السابقه وراح يكون في حرب ما بين فرنسا
والرايخ الرابع وتقسيم لاوروبا بما في ذلك
تقسيم بولندا الجديد الى جانب انه متوقع
فصل ايرلندا الشماليه عن مملكه بريطانيا
والانضمام لا جمهوريه ايرلندا
اما بالنسبه لتوقعاته الاكثر جدلا كانت
بتخص الولايات المتحده وتوقع حرب اهليه
امريكيه وانفصال كلفونيا وتكساس ليصيروا
دولتين مستقلتين وانشاء ولايه اتحاد تكساس
والمكسيك اما التوقع الاغرب بصراحه كان
انتصار ايلون ماسك اللاحق في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه في بعض الولايات
المخصصه للجمهوريين تحديدا بعد الحرب
الاهليه اللي توقعها لكن الملياردير
الامريكي الى الماسك رد على هيئه توقعات
وصفها بانها سخيفه وقال بتغريده على تويتر
انه هذه توقعات سخيفه وبتظهر نقص كبير في
الوعي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد على مدى ثلاثه ايام مضت
لا يزال اسم الفنان السعودي الراحل طلال
مداح من الاكثر تداولا وتفاعلا على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي بعد اعلان المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ عن حفله تكريم الاضخم
للراحل واللي يفور اعلاناتسابق عشرات
الفنانين للمشاركه تكريم صوت الارض ما
توقف عند 50 فنان وفنانه من السعوديه ومن
الخليج ومن العالم العربي اللي قرروا
المشاركه في تكريم الفنان الكبير بل تجاوز
الامر حتى جماهير الفنان الراحل الى
جماهير بقيه الفنانين اللي استذكروا اجمل
اغاني طلال واستعاده ابرز محطات الفنيه
اللي لا يمكن حصرها واحنا في تفاعلكم
قررنا نذهب للشارع السعودي في اكثر من
مدينه والتقينا بناس من مختلف الاعمار
والجنسيه وسالناهم سؤال واحد لو قدر لك وش
طلال في حياته ايش ممكن تقول له
[موسيقى]
اغاني كانت حلوه جدا وكان نفسي اكون عايشه
من زمان عشان اسمع اغانيه واحضر حفلاته
لانه فنان يعني عظيم
الجميل
اغانيك الخالده الى الان موجوده في قلوبنا
وذاكرتك وصورتك الى الان موجوده اذا شفت
الفنان الله يرحمه طلال مداح تقول اني
احبك اغاني
ذكرتني في الطفوله كثير همم التسعينات كنت
مره مشهور
دائما حلو
لن يتكرر ابدا كلنا نحبك يا طلال الصراحه
اغانيك في الذاكره مهما طال الزمن لو كان
موجود الان يعني ودي اقول له اغني لنا
زياد
يعني انا من المعجبين فيك دائما دائما
اسمع له دائما احب اغانيه بصراحه لو اني
كنت هالايام والله اني كل يوم راح احضر
حفلات فقدناك صوت الارض ااا كانت فتره
الفتره جميله كانت كانت اغاني عشاق
اتمنى ان شاء الله يطلع بالوقت قريب فنان
قريب منك على الاقل او في لمحه منك مع اني
انا ما اتوقع ان يتكرر صوتك ولا يتكرر
احساس
عاشور فاكسرني
الشارع في المنطقه الشرقيه دعونا نستطيع
الان معكم الاجابات في نفس على نفس السؤال
من الرياضه
[موسيقى]
وعلى الالحان على كل اغاني كل راسخه معنا
من واحنا صغار الين ما كبرنا وافضل اغنيه
انا احب احبها صراحه ودائما رددها تصدق
ولا احلف لك بلساني اوصفلك وحابه اني
صراحه اكون حاضره حفله كريمه
جدا
خلال الايام القادمه
اشكرك كذلك تركيا للشيخ
واللي بقدر اقوله الله يرحمك يا طلال مداح
طلال في قلوبنا طلال يعني ملك الاغنيه
السعوديه يعني طلال
طلال والله انه حي ما مات عندنا ابدا
صراحه انا حزين جدا اني ما لحقت عليك
المسرح
ومن اغانيه الكثير اللي نحافظ عليها انا
راجع اشوفك
طلال عندما يغني للحب لا يغني للحب هو
يغني بحب هو يعشق الحب ويعرف الحب حتى
اصبح يقدم لنا بطريقه يعجز اي احد عنده
بالنسبه للحفله والتكريم هذا اقل شيء هذا
اقل شيء صراحه وكنا ننتظر هذا الشيء من
زمان لكن الحقيقه مبادره موفقه ومبادره
جميله
اكيد انا بنكون من الحاضرين لهذه الحفله
فتحت لنا الفرصه ان شاء الله باذن الله
طلال مداح الله يرحم مالك انه موجود يشوف
المسيره اللي حاصله الان يشوف التطور اللي
حصل في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الحفلات الغنائيه الموسم همم حدث لا يكرر
كلمه شكر توجه لجميع الفنانين اللي يحيون
الليله اللي ان شاء الله بتكون ليله فريده
من نوعها اا مسيره لا تكرر للفنان الراحل
طلال مداح سيدنا
[موسيقى]
مش بس الناس بصراحه بتغمرها محبه طلال
مداح حتى الفنانين سواء من الموجودين او
الراحلين لهم قصص لا تعد ولا تحصى مع صوت
الارض من ابرزهم الراحل الكبير ابو بكر
سالم اللي رافق طلال من بدايته وجمعتهم
اعمال خالده حتى يومنا الحاضر خلونا
نستذكر معكم ملامح من العلاقه اللي امتدت
العقود
[موسيقى]
يا هلا حبيبي كيف الحال يا حبيبي كيف
الحال كل سنه وانت طيب حبيبي كل عام وانت
بخير كلهم الله يحفظك الله يحفظك حبيبي
طيبين كلهم
هل حصل
ابو بكر سالم تمنيت انك انت تغنيها وقلت
لها مثلا عبرت عن هذا الشيء
وايضا يمكن الفنان ابو بكر سالم
[موسيقى]
يعني اختار ما همم
طيب الوقت كثير ونغنيها انا وياه وهو ياخذ
وهكذا يعني
الاغنيه
يا حبيبي الله يحفظك
حبي
[موسيقى]
ما بين طرفه عين
راحه الفريق
وما بين طرفه عين
طاهر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الفنان الراحل طلال
يده الفنان عبادي
لرئيس يترفع والجوهر اللي كان اول من اعلن
المشاركه في تكريم صوت الارض اكد انه هذا
تسابق من الفنانين والفنانات للمشاركه هو
دليل على اهميه المكرمه
الله يمسيك بالخير يا ابو ناصر عساك بخير
طمني عن صحتك مو غريب هذا التفاعل من جميع
الفنانين الي يبدو استعدادا من المشاركه
في هذا الحفل لفنانه اعطل كثير الاغنيه
السعوديه وهذا حماس على الجميع هو للمكرم
وللمكرم فانت صاحب هذه المبادره الجميله
واهتمامك بالكل نابع من محبتك ودعمك الفن
والفنانين شكرا لكم
عضه
الابهام مدري نذم مدريني دم والاملام
[موسيقى]
خلي العاده الخلى الكلام
الا لعادل
[موسيقى]
خلي الفار تنام تنام مع طفل
وبالعوده لا بدايه طلال مداح اللي كانت
بدايات لا شعراء كبار في السعوديه والخليج
كان طلال اول من فتح لهم ابواب الشهره
دعونا نتابع مشاهدينا مع بعض هاي الكلمات
للشاعر الامير بدر بن عبد المحسن عن كيف
اصبح طلال ظاهره استثنائيه في تاريخ
الاغنيه العربيه وكيف كانت لحظه التعاون
الاولى بينهم
[موسيقى]
يعني في مطربين كثير موجودين
بس من المستحيل انك تقول هذا ظاهره
يعني ام كلثوم
[موسيقى]
انه كان له الفضل في الفضل كبير في في في
ظهور بدر بن عبد العزيز
المحطه الاولى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
محبه محبه
عم كفايات عطني
ابغى
وجود
عطني المحبه من ابرز اغنيات صوت الارض
طلال مداح في اواخر تجربته الفنيه الواسعه
اغنيه بعنوان خلصت القصه واحنا بنقول انه
القصه ما خلصت يا طلال وكلنا راجعين نشوفك
في اغنياتك باصوات فنانين وفنانات
السعوديه والخليج والعالم العربي في ليله
تكريمك المنتظره الى اللقاء
انا راجع اشوفك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسال
عنه
اسال عنه
كثيرا
الليالي
تاثير الليالي
[موسيقى]
عليه
ظروفها